[Musique]
Paris à ses pieds une atmosphère de luxe
un service feutré d'aîné de choix font
de ce restaurant l'un des atouts majeurs
d'une tour qui se veut prestigieuse
[Musique]
et bien voyez-vous quand cette grande
opération fut décide et en 1958 ça n'a
pas été le hasard une analyse très
poussée de sites avait été réalisés qui
aboutit à la conclusion que Montparnasse
est un des trois points de Paris les
mieux desservis en moyen de transport en
commun
les moyens de transport en commun ce
n'est pas parce que les crises récentes
en font parler mais c'est vraiment les
artères vitales d'une grande
agglomération qui dit transport en
commun dit moyen d'arriver rapidement en
un point c'est à dire moyen d'établir
des rencontres des échanges on Parnasse
c'était déjà des échanges c'était les
artistes du monde entier et bien les
échanges c'est aussi dans le monde
moderne la vie des affaires et c'est
essentiellement cet aspect de
communication facile qui a fait décider
cette opération puis par ailleurs la
ville a besoin de se rénover la ville
est un être vivant qui a besoin d'avoir
certains points forts on peut avoir du
tissu interstitiel plus léger consacré à
les résidences mais Paris a toujours été
une ville où le travail
coïncider avec la résidence le bureau et
l'atelier des temps modernes il ne faut
pas faire partir le travail de la ville
on peut l'emmener à l'extérieur pour des
besoins de desserment mais il faut
toujours que la ville reste un élément
un site pour le travail monsieur est-ce
que pour un PDG pouvait se permettre de
s'installer à la Tour Montparnasse ce
n'est pas un peu une consécration
pour certains peut-être enfin je
considère que dans la plupart des cas ce
n'est pas ça qu'il faut y voir il faut
considérer que l'installation dans la
tour doit être motivée par autre chose
qu'une carte de visite ou disons une
publicité de 200 mètres de haut le et en
ce qui concerne notre entreprise alors
absolument pas ça n'a pas été du tout
une opération prestige bien loin de là
ça a été après une étude assez
approfondie de ce que l'on cherchait de
ce que l'on voulait de ce que l'on
jugeait nécessaire pour la marge de
l'entreprise que nous avons décidé de
nous installer ici nous pouvions pas
être dans la périphérie
de Paris
d'autre part nous avons une société qui
n'est pas énorme mais avec un personnel
très intégré les gens travaillent tous
les uns avec les autres il n'y a pas de
cloison entre les services entre les
départements il était donc indispensable
que l'ensemble du personnel soit
rassemblés sur un seul niveau sur un
seul État sur notre plan ça évitait les
déperditions
d'énergie les je n'ose pas parler de
perte de productivité mais enfin on
pourrait le dire sur le temps passé en
circulation verticale
et ça c'était quand même très important
et ma foi ici nous allons trouver quand
même des niveaux d'une assez belle
superficie ceci dit dans ce qu'on est
bien obligé d'appeler la période de
crise actuelle vous ne pensez pas qu'il
y a là un risque parce que ça a dû vous
coûter très cher
c'est un risque certain
comme tous les risques il faut les
calculer avant
quand nous avons décidé de nous
installer ici c'était en
190 et 11 enfin 70 début 71
nous avons quand même calculé ce que
nous pouvions faire ce que nous pouvions
pas faire mais je veux dire une chose
c'est que à l'heure actuelle étant donné
la situation
économique situation commerciale
ne prendrions plus maintenant la même
décision
à quel étage sommes-nous ici madame nous
sommes au 43e
et vous n'êtes pas sujette au vertige ah
non pas du tout certaines personnes ici
mais moi personnellement depuis combien
de temps travaillez-vous dans la tour ça
va faire un an maintenant et le bilan
vous paierez comment satisfaisant
positif ou au contraire désagréable
écouter moi personnellement j'aime ma
sélection il y a des avantages et bien
sûr des inconvénients mais
les jeux d'abord commencé peut-être par
les inconvénients il était très
difficile de se faire à la climatisation
maintenant
certaines personnes moi je n'ai pas su
faire mais certaines personnes sont un
peu claustrophobe et ont besoin d'air si
vous voulez ce manque on peut pas ouvrir
les fenêtres c'est un peu il faut s'y
faire il faut s'habituer et
le fait aussi de rester dans la tour
toute la journée si vous voulez de 9
heures à 6h du soir puisqu'on a un
restaurant un restaurant d'entreprise
effectivement mais je crois qu'il faut
prendre une demi-heure trois quarts
d'heure pour sortir pour s'aérer un peu
pour
sortir un peu de la tour
le restaurant inter-entreprise dont tout
copropriétaire de la tour doit
obligatoirement assumer sa part de
charge est en réalité un livre service
mais un livre service de grande classe
par son aménagement à la foi rationnel
et agréable par le vaste choix des plats
offerts et par un louable effort
d'imagination qui permet aux habitués
s'ils le désirent d'introduire mille
fantaisies dans leur menu
un système de cartes payable d'avance
évite les longues files d'attente devant
la caisse
les salles peuvent sans accroc absorber
un roulement de 5500 couverts par repas
tous les jours est-ce que c'est bon vous
êtes contents
vous vous sentez privilégié parce que
vous travaillez dans la tour au
contraire victime mais victime
voilà des victimes qui paraissent bien
gaies en réalité le restaurant comme sa
coquette cafétéria ont surtout un défaut
ils sont en sous-sol ce qui explique ce
besoin des occupants de la tour de
prendre l'air durant la pause repas
qu'est-ce que vous faites durant cette
demi-heure de promenade
que vous connaissez qui est quand même
important énormément de boutiques
c'est un tout petit peu cher à mon avis
mais en fait c'est très pratique pour
les peu de temps que l'on a lorsqu'on a
fait des courses c'est quand même
agréable le très grand éventé je la tour
sa facilité d'accès sur tu vois mon avis
il y a des moyens de transport vraiment
très efficaces les autobus le métro la
gare enfin c'est vraiment très centrale
les ascenseurs comment sont-ils très
rapides vous avez pris l'ascenseur oui
j'ai pris l'ascenseur
direct pour le 43e étage et
moi c'est vous ne l'attendez jamais
4 ou 5 ascenseur
[Musique]
l'étage le plus surexcitant de la tour
est évidemment le dernier le 56e des
ascenseurs directs du conduisent
votre ascenseur montre quelle vitesse 6
mètres seconde il met combien de temps
pour parcourir les 56 étages 37 secondes
et vous faites ça combien de fois par
jour vous savez je les gros plus si vous
fatigue pas un petit peu les jambes ça
ne vous effraie pas de savoir que vous
avez en dessous de vous 200 mètres un
peu plus de 200 mètres un trou comme ça
puisse même pas
une large partie du 56e est occupée par
le restaurant panoramique
[Musique]
Paris a ses pieds une atmosphère de luxe
un service feutré des nez de choix font
de ce restaurant l'un des atouts majeurs
d'une tour qui se veut prestigieuse le
56e c'est aussi le belvédère
le belvédère paradis des enfants mais
également de tous les amoureux de Paris
à qui la découverte de leur ville vu
ainsi d'en haut procure un enchantement
sans fin plus que nulle part ailleurs
c'est ici que l'on peut se convaincre
que la tour Montparnasse malgré tous les
reproches qu'on s'accorde à loi dressées
fait largement teneur à ceux qui l'ont
conçu comme à ceux qui ont organisent
aujourd'hui l'existence est-ce que c'est
beau Paris vue d'en haut oui oui
c'est très joli c'est la première fois
que vous venez sur la tour
et ça vous plaît
vous aimeriez revenir oui
ça nous fait pas un peu peur cette
immense tour
vous aimeriez monter encore plus haut
le problème de mes distributions du
courrier n'a pas été l'un des moins
qu'il a fallu résoudre pour faciliter la
vie dans la tour
située lui aussi au deuxième sous-sol le
Cedex de la tour fait office de bureau
de poste miniature capacité 60
000 lettres et colis par jour nous avons
assisté aux opérations depuis l'arrivée
du courrier et au tri jusqu'au moment où
les occupants de la tour viennent vider
leurs quasi respectifs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur la puissance économique du
Japon lui permet d'être présent à
l'heure actuelle à peu près partout il
est donc pas étonnant pour nous de
trouver que ce 35e étage d'un tout
Montparnasse est en fait un état
japonais oui j'aimerais quand même que
vous me disiez qu'est-ce qui a pu
convaincre une grande société de
commerce international tels que la vôtre
une société japonaise donc de
s'installer à la Tour Montparnasse et
bien du fait comme vous avez dit de la
puissance économique japonaise et de
l'expansion de notre société il nous a
fallu quelque chose de comme disent les
angles up today de tout à fait moderne
et la tour que nous fournissait
l'espace la commandité n'est-ce pas et
là pour une société dans notre standing
parmi toutes les succursales de notre
société et nous en avons 100 à peu près
outre-mer c'est la plus belle et la
mieux aménager nous pouvons dire
ne craignez rien ne tourne pas près de
s'écrouler nous sommes au deuxième
sous-sol au poste de sécurité
cet appareil permet le contrôle constant
de toutes les installations techniques
de la tour il indique par exemple la
distance la température des 3000 points
les plus vitaux de ces installations
quant à ce pupitre couplé à un système
de ronde et de surveillance il permet de
donner l'alerte au moindre incident
pour un exercice au troisième étage
intervention entendu nous arrivons
tout ce qui a été inventé de mieux pour
combattre les incendies a été prévu dans
la tour les plafonds sont hérissés de
détecteur de chaleur ou de fumée
des colonnes humides cours le long des
niveaux elles peuvent écraser sous leurs
et puissant n'importe quel foyer qui se
déclarerait des portes coupe-feu placées
aux endroits névralgiques isolent en
quelques secondes tous secteurs menacés
leur fermeture bloque automatiquement la
marche des ascenseurs
la tour compte 25 ascenseurs de
montcharge et faites extrêmement rare 4
escaliers de secours nous nous trouvons
dans une des salles de contrôle des
ascenseurs ici tout est programmé
électroniquement ces appareils prennent
en charge les différentes cabines leur
assure un équilibre constant règle leur
vitesse commande leur arrêt en douceur
monsieur lorsque la tour sera
complètement habité elle hébergera tous
les jours une population de 25000
personnes c'est-à-dire l'équivalent
d'une sous-préfecture comme Chartres
alors qu'est-ce que ça représente que
d'être le syndicte d'un tel ensemble et
bien effectivement c'est une ville une
petite ville dans la ville où se pose
tous les problèmes d'une ville les
services techniques car il faut fournir
le froid le chaud les services
d'entretien nous avons
200 à 250 personnels d'entretien femme
de ménage qui prennent possession de ces
immeubles le soir
les services de gardiennage car en
gardien les pompiers la sécurité car
nous avons 40 pompiers attachés cet
immeuble et la sécurité est à nos
impératifs majeur
et puis aussi il est les rapports
j'allais dire d'un maire avec ses
concitoyens car le syndic est un homme
élu toutes les années et l'assemblée
générale des copropriétaires
choisis le samedi donc effectivement
c'est une ville avec des rapports aussi
de solidarité cette ville s'organise peu
à peu les tas de choses qui vont très
au-delà de ce que l'on peut penser dans
un ensemble immobilier se mettent en
place récemment les copropriétaires ont
souhaité instaurer pour le personnel des
cours de formation permanent des cours
de langue des cours des techniques de
communication on peut à peu dans ces
immeubles conçus par nous s'instaure la
vraie vie avec en plus la chose
merveilleuse d'avoir cette ville vous
dites charme moi je dis généralement
Bar-le-Duc qui est dans un des quartiers
les plus vivants de Paris et que nous
voulons absolument maintenir dans Paris
et nous faisons pas une bande à part
nous sommes dans la ville et la ville
nous rend beaucoup ce que nous espérons
lui avoir apporté
18h la tour à chef de se vider de ses
occupants
les dernières grappes d'employés
s'écoule des ascenseurs vers la sortie
c'est à ce moment que le bataillon du
service d'entretien
il se répand dans les étages et
entreprend dans le fracas des machines à
laver les carreaux ou des aspirateurs à
grande puissance de faire la toilette de
la tour
[Rires]
au même moment la tour se débarrasse de
ses cartons de ces cageots de ces
papiers de ses emballages de ses déchets
et détritus de toutes sortes
153 mètres cubes tous les jours qui leur
était impossible de traiter sans se
compacteur installé au deuxième sous-sol
qui réduit en moyenne ce qu'il absorbe à
6% de son volume initial
lorsque le caisson du contacteur est
plein il ne reste plus au camion grue
qu'elle emporter vers une des usines de
récupération d'ordures de la région
parisienne
je vous répète ma question bilan
favorable défavorable favorable
de travailler à la nature franchement
[Musique]